foreign
which is who runs the world
it used to be an easy question to answer
if you're over 45 like me
you grew up in a world that was
dominated by two giants
the United States called the shots on
one side of the wall
the Soviets set the rules on the other
and that was a bipolar world
it's very simple
if you're under 45
you grew up when the Soviet Union had
already collapsed
and that left the United States as the
sole superpower
dominating Global institutions and also
exerting raw power
and that
was a unipolar world
and then about 15 years ago
things got a little more complicated
the United States
increasingly didn't want to be the
world's policeman
or the architect of global trade or even
the cheerleader for Global values
other countries were becoming more
powerful and they could increasingly
ignore many of the rules they didn't
like sometimes even setting new rules
themselves
what happened
three things
number one
Russia was not integrated into Western
institutions
a form of great power now in very
serious Decline and they are angry about
it
we can argue about whose fault that is
but we are where we are
number two
China was integrated into U.S led
institutions on the presumption that as
they got wealthier and more powerful
they would become Americans
turns out
they're still Chinese
and the United States is not
particularly comfortable with that
number three
tens of millions of citizens in the
United States and other wealthy
democracies felt left behind by
globalization this has been ignored for
decades but as a consequence they felt
that their governments and their leaders
were more illegitimate
now
if you look at all the headlines in the
world today driving all of this
geopolitical tension and conflicts over
90 percent of them are because of these
three reasons
and that's why today we live in a
leaderless world
but as We Know
that's not going to be with us for long
so what comes next
what kind of a world order might we
expect over the next 10 years
some of what I might say I think will
surprise you
because we're not going to have
a bipolar or a unipolar or even a
multi-polar world if we don't have one
or two superpowers we don't have a
single Global Order no instead we will
have three different orders
a little overlapping
and the third will have immense
importance
for how we live what we think
what we want
and what we're prepared to do to get it
but first things first
today we have a Global Security order
and as you see from the map the United
States and its allies are the most
powerful players on it the US is the
only country in the world that can send
its soldiers and its Sailors and its
military equipment to every corner of
that world no one else close
China is growing in its military
capabilities in Asia though nowhere else
lots of American Allies in Asia are
concerned about that and as a
consequence they're becoming more
dependent on the United States for a
security
umbrella
with the Russian invasion of Ukraine U.S
allies in Europe are becoming more
concerned and dependent on the United
States and a U.S led NATO
the Russian military of course has been
a greater Global concern much less so
today especially as they've lost over
200 000 troops and all of that equipment
and with sanctions making it extremely
hard for them to rebuild
now Russia and China and others have
nuclear weapons but thank God it is
still suicide to use them and as a
consequence our security order is a
unipolar order and it is likely to
remain so for the next decade
now at the same time that there's a
security order
there's also a global economic order
and hear power is shared
the United States is still
a very robust global economy but the U.S
can't use its dominant position
militarily to tell other countries what
to do economically
the United States and China are
enormously economically interdependent
and so they can't control each other you
may be surprised to hear this but today
U.S China trade relations are actually
at their highest level in history
now other countries in the world a lot
of them want access to U.S military
muscle but they also want access to the
Chinese market soon by 2030 likely to be
the largest in the world and you can't
very well have a cold war if the U.S and
the Chinese are the only two that are
prepared to fight it
yes yes
so the European Union has the largest
common market
and they set the rules and if you want
to do profitable business there you
listen to those rules
India is playing a greater role
economically on the global stage Japan
still matters too and over the next 10
years there will be a rise and fall of
the relative capacities of these
economies but the global economic order
is and will remain a multi-polar order
now between these two orders are
attentions
because the United States will use its
power in National Security to try to
bring more of the world's economies
towards it and we already see this
starting to happen in semiconductors and
in critical minerals and maybe soon in
Tick Tock the Chinese are trying to use
their dominant commercial position to
align more of the world diplomatically
and Japan and Europe and India and
everyone else will do their damnedest to
ensure that neither of these two orders
dominate the other
and they will mostly succeed
now so far I have spoken with you about
the two World orders we already see
but there's a third that is coming soon
that's even more important
and that
is the digital order
and the digital order is not run by
governments
but by technology companies
we all know how much Military Support
NATO countries have provided Ukraine
during the war
but its technology companies that
provided the tools allowing Ukraine to
defend itself from Russian Cyber attack
its technology companies that gave the
Ukrainian leaders the ability to speak
with their generals and their soldiers
on the front lines
if it wasn't for those technology
companies Ukraine would have been fully
offline within weeks of the war and I
don't believe President zielinski would
still be there today
technology companies determine whether
Donald Trump is able in real time and
without filter to speak with hundreds of
millions of people as he runs again for
the presidency
it's social media platforms and their
ability to promote disinformation and
Conspiracy Theory without them we do not
have
riots in the capital on January 6. we do
not have trucker riots in Ottawa we do
not have a January 8th Insurrection in
Brazil
technology companies increasingly
determine our identities
when I was growing up it's nature and
nurture I mean my deep and abiding
emotional problems either come from how
I was raised
or some genetic failure
could be both
but today
our identities are determined by nature
and nurture and algorithm
if if you want to challenge the system
you can't just question authority as we
were all told when we're growing up
today you have to question the algorithm
and that is a staggering amount of power
in the hands of these technology
companies
what are they going to do with that
power
and that depends on who they want to be
when they grow up
so if China and the United States work
to exert much more power
over
the digital world and technology
companies in those countries align with
those governments we will end up in a
technology Cold War
and that means the digital order will be
split in two
if on the other hand
technology companies persist
with global business models
and we retain competition between the
digital and physical worlds
we will have a new globalization a
digital Global Order
or if the digital order becomes
increasingly dominant
and governments erode in their capacity
to govern and we've already seen the
beginning of this
technology companies will become the
dominant actors on the global stage in
every way
and we will have a techno polar order
and that will determine
whether we have a world of Limitless
opportunity
or a world without freedom
now at this point in my speech
I'm supposed to talk about the good news
but those of you that have heard this
know that that is not coming
there is no pause button on these
explosive and disruptive Technologies I
I don't know if you know this there are
over a hundred people in the world today
with the knowledge and the technology to
create a new smallpox virus
honestly I don't have answers
but I have a few questions
for the people that do
because these technology companies are
not just Fortune 50 and 100 actors
these technology Titans are not just men
worth 50 or 100 billion dollars or more
they are increasingly the most powerful
people on the planet with influence over
our futures
and we need to know
are they going to act accountably as
they release new and Powerful artificial
intelligence
what are they going to do with this
unprecedented amount of data that they
are collecting on us and our environment
and the one that I think should concern
us all right now the most
will they persist with these advertising
models driving so much revenues that are
turning citizens into products and
driving hate and misinformation and
ripping apart our society
when I was a student back in 1989
and the wall fell
the United States was the principal
exporter of democracy in the world
not always successfully
often hypocritically
but number one nonetheless
today the United States has become the
principal exporter of tools that destroy
democracy
the technology leaders who create and
control these tools
are they okay with that
or are they going to do something about
it
we need to know
thank you
foreign